President Trump has until 6 o'clock
tonight to respond to a summons in his
impeachment trial that begins next week
we also now know who will defend the
president and his team includes several
controversial figures mr. Trump is
spending the weekend at his Florida
resorts and Nikole Killion is traveling
with the president and joins us from
West Palm Beach Florida Nicole good
morning good morning to you Jeff and the
president's legal counsel as well as
impeachment managers in the house will
be very busy this weekend preparing for
the upcoming Senate trial with opening
arguments due to start Tuesday as
president Trump arrived at West Palm
Beach on his way to attend a high-dollar
fundraiser at his Mar Lago Resort Friday
night the White House released a list of
who will represent him at his upcoming
Senate trial leading the team White
House Counsel Pat's abalone and mr.
Trump's private attorney Jay Sekulow
we're ready to get this behind us the
roster includes half-a-dozen attorneys
including constitutional law professor
Alan Dershowitz
I've been asked to prepare and deliver
the case the constitutional case against
impeachment that benefits the president
and former special prosecutor Ken Starr
best known for the investigation that
led to President Bill Clinton's
impeachment the former intern at the
center of the case Monica Lewinsky
tweeted are you blank kidding me I think
that Ken Starr is a disaster while the
President had a different opinion of
Starr back then some White House aides
are expressing concern now both star and
Dershowitz once represented convicted
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein Dershowitz was
also on OJ Simpson's defense team and
was accused of sexual assault which he
denies but a White House adviser tells
CBS News the President believes the pair
will make for great TV ratings a lot of
presidents some good some not so good
but you got a good one now even though
they're trying to impeach the
son-of-a-bitch the president lashed out
at Democrats who released new evidence
from former Giuliani associate left
Parnas including photos of partisan
Trump and messages with congressional
aides President was self impeaching
almost every single day House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi says the president's
actions will be a stain on his record
the Senate does it can never be erased
so I want him to know that he is
impeached for ever but president's a
personal attorney Rudy Giuliani is not
expected to join his defense team
although he said he will still continue
to advise the president as lawmakers
sort through all of this new evidence
they will also have to decide whether or
not to hear from additional witnesses
Jeff okay Nicole thank you very much
you